[Musica]
signore e signori la squadra di oggi e
composta da rozzano rapinatore di
capelli ha fatto sparire pur i suoi
parabiago parcheggiatore abusivo di
mezzi militari
venaria esperto di schiaffi a mano
armata colonia esperto di sostanze
esplosive
messina giampiero
siracusa il legal streaming a fano di
caselle falsificatore di pagellini
scolastici
patan
sono stati ascoltati
aiutati a questo punto non sarà facile
dovete attenervi anche altri con voi c'è
uno dei nostri fate i conti pd ce la
dovete essere molto veloci
pochissimo tempo ma non dovete fuori
paura io non sarò qui mattia in chiaro
da fuori
sono stato io
[Musica]
vincere gianluca
signori e signori benvenuti la rapina
del secolo
da questo momento voi fate parte della
nostra banda avete sentito il professore
abbiamo bisogno di voi nei vostri
talenti lo stato cioè dichiarato guerra
una guerra sporca
se noi siamo la resistenza e non ci
nasconderemo punto primo nessun
relazione personale
secondo non versiamo nessun tipo di
goccia di sangue
siamo dei robin hood non siamo dei
criminali siamo un gruppo dobbiamo fare
il lavoro di squadra
forza ragazzi si no dai dai dai mente
fredda tumore chiari ha ufficialmente
inizio il pianto
andiamo allora ragazzi ma quando di
caselle dicendo siamo di vita al 100 i
gruppi con me arrabbiato cui vieni lo
sarò anche per cena ok ragazzi tutti gli
altri non mi dicono i nomi d'altra parte
sono dei telefoni sui tavoli ok quindi è
sicuramente un segno o chiave dovete
cambiare operatore o semplicemente
perché possiamo usarli per entrare
dentro il cavo ok no non me frega niente
una volta rispetto a quelli di oggi sono
molto più indistruttibile volete che
possiamo usarli per tirarli sul cavo
toni ed entrare dentro quindi mettete mi
telefono in più indistruttibili davanti
e quelli che si parla di caselle altro
tavolo chi ci sta
ragazzi metà gruppo nell'altro tavolo
forza diviso 27 diviso due fa 3,5
spezzati a metà bike il primo papa noi
dobbiamo lavorarci al cavo come ci
arriviamo al calcio è un computer
maledizione nessuno l'ha visto
chi sa inglese di voi io credo che ci
sia scritto inserire delle code delle
cose inserisci il codice copiano il
casello ricerchiamo dappertutto intanto
anche ora che dovunque larry non li
posso toccare non ho mai aperti nella
mia vita non vi aprirò ha detto altro
di guardare dentro la gente abbia
attirato tanta non c'è niente niente vi
parlo di ballo niente la sorte di un
esercizio non c'è niente sul rosso sarà
un addio vera che non è gira la moda è
continuiamo cioè quasi il telefono e tu
non mi trovi il telefono i colori mica
bene per parlare di customizzazione la
cosa più importante qui sotto ma c'è un
passato come fai sapere se il film bosco
questo è una simbolica grande questo
inserisci il codice qui messina si monta
i video inserisci cose e allora capacità
ok niente allora dobbiamo fare un po di
training maggiore ma va bene così
abbiamo fatto anche per 20 mag anno del
professore nostro uomo ce l'ha fatta
siamo pronti per accedere alla prossima
stazza ci dà il via libera
si ok ok via b
allora ragazzi in qualche modo dobbiamo
riuscire a passare alla stanza
successiva ci sono dei terminali che io
non riesco neanche a montarmi il modem a
casa mia quindi non di quello nuovo
tocco io per favore venarìa vai con
siracusa al terminale perfetto con me
parabiago e messina ok rozzano e cologno
al tavolo limite come allora ragazzino
io provo a smontare questa casa voi fate
gli diamo cinque gruppi in questo mini
gruppo molto questa voi montate l'altra
ma c'è un codice
anche qui sono di numero di modello 2019
e quello sotto non lo so letto ragazzi
cercate di venirne a capo vado vedere
cosa fanno gli altri cologno razzano che
state facendo ho trovato qualcosa o per
la trovato qualcosa per sé sono
cartoline per la nonna prima come sono
coordinate o sono certo quadro delle
armi ma avanti facendo penalità che ci
avete fatto voi noi abbiamo fatto in
formato da lui ma li prendeva 3 un
casino abbiamo rubato tutto l'eroe si
nobile dobbiamo inserire questi così qua
in base al codice che abbiamo trovato
però è difficile devo capire cosa stanno
facendo
torno a capire come dobbiamo mettere
stick all arrivo hanno trovato un modem
con la linea veramente lenta a niente ci
sono dei codici che bisogna inserire i
cavi dentro abbiamo giocato lei è una
cosa importantissima razzisti tv non ho
capito assolutamente nulla neanche io
niente ecco io sono il capo squadra non
troviamo il codice non capivo il codice
cologno hai controllato
no questi sono i compiti per le vacanze
io ho provato ha lottato macigno ma ci
manca una casella ci manca una casella
quel pezzo di carta cioè non c'è c'è in
ogni non secondo abbiamo la chiamo la
bene a 1 è ovvio qua non c'è niente ecco
la salute dove siamo noi guardiamo che
combacia lombardo questore cosa dice
dobbiamo comunicare al professore le
coordinate della planimetria ok e poi
passare ai cari corsa di mele ma fano e
43 secondi 84 primi 59 secondi 93 53 un
tè quello a nord nord no 10 gradi 50 50
secondi 61 e corretta
dobbiamo inserire i cavi in base al
codice che abbiamo trovato quindi da te
mi domando no no no no guarda ci sono
dei codici ok il numero per il prudente
l'ho fatto le elementari nota ma questo
è il 6 5 4 melo è un 3 un 3 3 ma rientra
quello di milano rozzano mi 12 lontano
da casa 2 arrivo subito ci siamo a posto
legale caso siamo però pensare a cosa
dice professoressa reali sono a posto
anche le altre prove si siamo pronti può
attivare laser ok via via via via
gazzani
sta funzionando dovremo essere ci siamo
mai terapia per la stessa rotta non ci
sono si sono visti gen
e allora
ciao bella ciao ciao
l'addio di mercato
ciao ciao
[Applauso]
tutta questa notte di fare ciao ragazzi
siamo stati noi siamo stati
non siamo criminali siamo stati
criminali sono loro due c'è un terzo lo
zio 6 pelato 6 criminale e per l'altro
baby alcune mi aveva però infamato uno
di noi una banalità della vita
vabbè uno in meno da spartire
[Musica]
niente
secondo me in questo momento sta godendo
di brutto ci mancherebbe
[Musica]
che figura rabbia che abbiamo un
problema
la tuta non entra cologno per favore
nostra non ci sei volte invece accetta
usa come coperta ma vabbè che pensava di
martin ex guarda euro neanche
21 per il nostro peso con innocenti come
mai allora puoi usare per verifiche
incubo prossimo temi che vi farà un
video guarda